And here we are going to talk about
basic strategy and that would be based
on similarity of users and then
predicting the rating of.
An object via active user.
Using the ratings of similar users to
this active user, this is called a memory
based approach.
Because it's a little similar to
storing all the
user information and when we are
considering a particular user, we're
going to try to retrieve the relevant
users or the similar users to this user
case and then try to use that user
information about those users to
predict the preference of this user.
So here's the general idea, and we use
some notations here so X_ij denotes
the rating of object o_j by user u_i.
And n_i is the average rating of all
objects by this user.
So.
This n_i is needed because we would like
to normalize the ratings of objects by
this user.
So how do you do normalization?
Well, we're going to just
subtract the average rating from all the
ratings. Now this is it will normalize
these ratings so that the ratings from
different users would be comparable.
Because some users might be more
generous and they generally given high
ratings.
But some others might be more critical,
so their ratings cannot be directly
compared with each other or aggregate
them together.
So we need to do this normalization.
Now the prediction of the rating on the
item by another user or active user.
u_ a here.
Can be based on the average ratings of
similar users.
So the user u_a is the user that
we're interested in recommending items
to and
We now are interested in recommending
this o_j, so we're interested
in knowing how likely this user will
like this objec.
How do we know that?
The idea here is to look at whether
similar users to this user have liked
this object.
So mathematically, this is to say the
predicted the rating of this user on
this object user A on object o_j is
basically combination of the normalized
ratings of different users.
And in fact here we're taking a sum
over all the users.
But not all users contribute equally to
the average, and this is controlled by
the weights.
So this.
Weight
Controls the influence of user on the
prediction.
And of course, naturally, this way that
should be related to the similarity
between u_a and this particular user u_i.
The more similar they are, then the
more contribution would like a user UI
to make in predicting the preference of
u_a
So the formula is extremely simple.
You can see it's a sum over all the
possible users.
And inside the sum,
We have their ratings, well, their
normalized ratings as I just explained,
the ratings need to be normalized in
order to be comparable with each
other.
And then these ratings are weighted by
their similarity.
So you can imagine W of a an I is just
a similarity of user A and user I.
Now what's k here, well k is
simply normalizer, it's just it's just
one over the sum of all the weights.
over all the users.
And so this means basically, if you
consider the weight here together with K
and we have coefficients or weights
that would sum to one for all the
users.
And it's just a normalization strategy
so that you get this predicted rating
in the same range as the these ratings
that we use to make the prediction.
Right, so this is basically the main
idea of memory based approaches for
collaborative filtering.
Once we make this prediction.
We also would like to map back to the
rating that the user
would actually make and this is
to
Further add the mean rating or average
rating of this user u_a to the
predicted value.
This would recover a meaningful rating
for this user.
So if this user is generous than the
average would be somewhat high and when
we add that the rating will be
adjust to a relatively high rating.
Now when you recommend.
Item to a user.
This actually doesn't really matter
'cause you're interested in.
Basically the normalized rating that's
more meaningful, but when they evaluate
these collaborative filtering approaches.
is that typically assume the actual
ratings of the user on these objects to be unknown,
and then you do the prediction and then
you compare the
Predicted ratings with their actual
ratings so they you do have access to
their actual ratings, but then you
pretend you don't know.
And then you compare your system's
predictions with the actual ratings.
In that case, obviously the systems
prediction would have to be adjusted to
match the actual ratings of the user,
and this is what's happening here,
basically.
OK, so this is the memory based
approach.
Now of course if you look at the
formula if you want to write the
program to implement it, you still face
the problem of determining what is this
W function right?
Once you know the W function, then the
formula is very easy to implement.
So indeed there are many different ways
to compute this function or this weight, w
and specific approaches generally differ
in how this is computed.
So here are some possibilities and you
can imagine.
There are many other possibilities.
One popular approach is to use the
Pearson correlation coefficient.
This would be a sum over commonly rated
items and the formula is a standard
Pearson correlation coefficient formula
as shown here.
So this basically measures whether the
two users tend to all give higher
ratings to similar items, or lower
ratings to similar items.
Another measure is the cosine measure,
and this is to treat the rating
vectors as vectors in the vector space.
And then we're going to measure the
angle and then compute the cosine of the
angles of the two vectors, and this
measure has been used in the vector
space model for retrieval as well.
So as you can imagine, there are many
different ways of doing that.
In all these cases, note that the user
similarity is based on their
preferences on
Items and we did not actually use any
content
information of these items.
It didn't matter what these items are.
They can be movies they can book so
they can be products.
They can be text documents.
We just didn't care about the content.
And
So this allows such approach to be
applied to a wide range of problems.
Now, in some new approaches, of course
we would like to use more information
about the user.
Clearly we know more about the user,
not just these preferences on these
items.
So, in the actual filtering system
using collaborative filtering.
We could also combine that with content
based filtering.
We could use more context information
and those are all interesting
approaches that people are still
studying.
There are new approaches proposed, but
this memory based approach.
It has been shown to work reasonably well
and it's easy to implement and
in practical application
this could be a starting point to see
if the strategy works well for your
application.
So there are some obvious ways to also
improve this approach.
And mainly we would like to improve the
user similarity measure and there are
some practical issues to deal with here
as well.
So for example, there will be a lot of
missing values.
What do you do with them?
Or you can set them to default values,
or the average ratings of the user and
that would be a simple solution, but
there are the advanced approaches that
can actually try to predict those
missing values.
And then use the predicted values to
improve the similarity.
So in fact the memory based approach you
can predict those missing values right?
So you can imagine you have iterative
approach where you first do some
preliminary prediction and then you can
use the predicted values to further
improve the similarity function.
So this is.
Here is a way to solve the problem and
the strategy obviously would affect the
performance of collaborative filtering.
Just like any other heuristics to
improve these similarity functions,
another idea which is actually very
similar to the idea of IDF that we have
seen in
Text research is called inverse user
frequency.
Or IUF
Now here the idea is to look at the
where the two users share similar
ratings.
If the item is a popular item that has
been viewed by many people, and seeing
these two people.
Interested in this item
May not be so interesting, but if it's
a rare item it has not been viewed by
many users, but these two users viewed
this item and they give similar ratings
and that says more about their
similarity, right?
So it's kind of to emphasize more on
similarity on items that are not viewed
by many users.